バンキラジオはいあねちゃん夜ご飯は
焼き肉よなんだよこれ足りないよショピ
シピシッピーシピシッピーシピシピシピ
お母さん自分のことにお金使いすぎなんだ
よショッピーの方が大事なのあんたお得意
の機会とかで遊んで
なさいはい炎で攻撃しました暴剤2年以下
の懲役また30万以下の罰金律ばっかり
うるさい
国民の皆さん自然災害法新しく法律を追加
いたします総理大臣になれば法律変え
られるのか私総理大臣になるわ何言ってん
の
[音楽]
バカバカし最強刀の神きこですショッピー
を守ります
何待ちなさいよちょっと待ちなさい待ち
なさいよちょっとこうなったら
[音楽]
これはだめだ他のもの考え
なさいあんたが総理なんなんだ君はんなん
だ君はおあんた総理大臣を譲りなさいさも
なく
[音楽]
ば本日より神きこ君を総理大臣にします新
総理大臣になりました神きこですまずは
言語を令和
から太に変えます渡翔太最高ピピピ
てるョ
ハゲダが食べたいわねお待たせしました
リハゲダッツがいっぱいだち総理大臣
[音楽]
最高のお母さん総理大臣になったねあいつ
馬から困ったよ早くやめてくんないかな
どうやらやめるのは先生の方かもしれない
え頭より体を鍛える必要がありますなので
授業は体育だけにしますそして体育教師
以外は全員首にします体育教師以外は
[音楽]
逮捕から来たしまし今日からお前たちを
鍛える1時間目は体育だ体育なんて最高
[音楽]
じゃん全スクワット1億回えト
1はい
2はい
[音楽]
[拍手]
900万
[音楽]
9500万
900万まだなしんねちゃんとせえよ
こりゃダメ
だということで完全についてきこ総理のご
意見を頂戴できればとなんかめどくさいわ
ね総理いい加減にしてください国民も怒っ
てます総理の仕事は国を守ることです勝て
することでは
首首首首
首そしてマ内閣の完成
やーマチ最高あねえねえねえこんな法律
どうかしらわからないけどいいと思います
そうよねじゃ新しい法律作っ
ちゃう渡翔太がこの世で一番尊いですなの
で全てのお店はショッピーグッズ以外売っ
てはいけない法律を作り
[音楽]
ますってきますいってらっしゃい学校
頑張って
ね打つしか売ってません本当かお前帰るぞ
はやめてくださいやめて
くださいお前ショッピーグッズ以外を売っ
ているな営業
達しは俺も俺も無駄無駄無駄無駄無駄無駄
無無
無無駄駄無無無
てちょっと待って待っ
てねえねこれ私の仕事らしいんだけどやっ
といてくんない
やあ全然わからないなああそうだ聞取りに
ちょうどいいかも
123おいゆと遊ぼうよはい何
えどうなってるんだこれ新しい総理大臣が
ショッピーのグッズしか売っちゃいけな
いって法律を作っちゃったからみんな仕事
がなくなっちゃったんだよごめんね魔王僕
の家お金持ちだったんだけどピンポになっ
ちゃったまずいぞこのままだと日本が
終わるここは俺が行くしかない
なおしだおだしおかしいおかしいおかしい
おかし
おかしい総理
ソリえやすがこちらに向かってるとの報告
が入りました屋根ちゃんねま自衛隊使って
ボコボコにしてちょうだい
[音楽]
バリアお
こういう時のために家にミサイルを搭載し
ててよかった
よ待ってろよ
お母さんあのマッチをどかさないと
お母さんにバレるなそう
だあプロテインだわあわあ
[音楽]
あああらやちゃんいつからいたのお母さん
もう総理大臣はやめろやめるわけないしょ
バリ遅い
あ
は
ああははは
う日本が終わるぞいい加減やめろ知らない
わやめたくないものいい加減に
[音楽]
しろ
あハゲ
だっちへ
ああやったかよくもやったわねうわ
あ見ろみんな困ってるんだお母さん暴走を
やめてくれ娘の生活を返し
[音楽]
て響が起きましたこんな情勢の中千年に
1度の嵐が日本レトを遅い大洪水の予想
です本わもう終わり
で千年にきの大わしだはあである私が子供
たちを気つけちゃいけないわね私やりすぎ
たって認める
わ私は総理大臣よこの国を守るのよわ
れ
たやったやった
[音楽]
お母さん屋根ちゃんみんなに悪いことした
わね私総理大臣なんて向いてなかったわ
本当だよ前の総理に戻した方がいいわよね
これイ
人情私がこの人情を前の総理に届けてき
ますきこさんは休んでありがとうござい
ますきこさんお大事
に私が総理大臣をやめてから日本は経済
回復をし日常が戻ったいらっしゃいませ
お母さん行ってくるねあ行ってらっしゃい
あこれ持っていこうほらこれはお店のだ
からだめでしょ全じゃあ行ってくるね気を
つけて
ねお母さんが総理大臣やめてよかった何
をまし全総理のきこから任命を受けました
新総理のハワイです総理最高
持ちいい
お前ミ俺リあごめご怒っちゃった怒っ
ちゃったごめごめごめ
遊
野郎
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録チャンネル
登録よろしくチャンネル登録チャンネル
登録チャンネル登録よろしく最初はグ
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録チャンネル
登録